Just a few weeks ago, the Huffington Post published this article.
Yeah, um,
I really don't care to hear another leftist media organization
whine about anybody inciting violence
ever again. These are the same people who condemn stochastic terrorism,
think so many different types of speech should be banned,
should be illegal. They don't even play by their own rules.
And for a while, I think a lot of Americans just didn't really care.
I think we figured, well,
these news organizations have been around for so long,
like, they must be credible.
But now it's like we're not falling for it anymore.
You people are hypocrites.
This kind of divisiveness,
this kind of hypocrisy is not journalism.
You have these celebrities enacting violent acts towards Donald Trump,
but it. It doesn't count because as Donald Trump.
Right, but anybody else would be put into prison for what, say,
Kathy Griffin did few years ago.
Nobody should play by their rules anymore,
because they don't even play by them.
They have zero credibility,
because according to their own standards,
they incite violence and they don't care.